the postman is oh yah today ask a doctor
Club the memory limitations una
dirección de que hasta por el dia que
están de la Purisima utonium when the
finest mo SI rakesh don't do the wallet
in anticipation for possible
restrictions on cash management's cash
payments exceeding certain thresholds we
also asked the Commission to engage with
the ECB to consider possible measures
regarding high denomination notes in
particular the 500 euro note our common
interests and this is a very strong
feeling among all ministers is that the
UK of course stays part of the European
Union there's a strong will to move
forward also to move forward of course
with the integration of the euro area
and our British colleague underlined the
importance of this also and to preserve
the integrity of the single market those
are our key joint priorities in its
comments accompanying the recommendation
the council regrets that the error rate
remained high for a significant part of
the budget notably for policy areas such
as cohesion rural development and
research the proposed amendment of the
first anti-money-laundering directive
will be our first legislative step other
steps will follow for example this
spring the Commission will work on
legislative proposals to complete and
improve the rules on asset freezes we
need to reduce the time it takes to
transpose united nations listings under
the al-qaeda and dash regimes into the
EU law we also need to make sure that
the new UN listings are made accessible
to EU financial and economic operators
immediately after their publications at
UN level we will also propose a
legislation to harmonize definitions of
member states criminal offences and
sanctions for money laundering today all
member states have made money laundering
illegal but there are differences
between member states as to the
definition of money
pounding and the sanctions applied these
differences create obstacles in
cross-border judicial and police
cooperation to tackle this crime our
objective is to present proposals by the
end of 2016 to amend to change the
situation if we are successful in our
fight against tax avoidance it will mean
more money for public budgets clearly
it's urgent to act now and our member
states clearly share the need to tackle
this issue and we fully support the
presidency's ambition to move forward
swiftly on adopting this package